how many times do you say i love you
oh that's a good question to how many
people do you say i love you
oh that's that's that's an even juicy
question
i say it multiple times to multiple guys
um tasha adams our bachelorette
[Laughter]
can you believe it's been a journey
years in the making
how surprised were you what was your
reaction when you got the call
are you kidding me this is a
conversation that i've had multiple
times
um and i kind of wrote it off at this
point and so when i did get the phone
call i was like
hold on what um i was shocked
it's obviously really exciting so how
how are you emotionally and mentally
right now are you happy
you know i'm happy and part of the
reason is because i can finally say i'm
the bachelorette
it's been a secret i've been holding on
to for a long long time
i mean claire went into the season
having been quarantined and i do think
that put her in a certain mental place
what was your mindset going in
i didn't really have too much time to
think about it and
the one opportunity i had to think about
was the fact that my heart
is ready and so with those intentions i
just kind of went with it
i'm coming here with the purist of
intentions and i just want you guys to
be real
i got married and divorced at a really
young age and i feel like this is my
time
to really dive in deep and find my life
partner
how quickly were you in quarantine at
laquinta and how long were you in
quarantine before you were stepping out
of that limo
um i was in quarantine within like 48
hours of that phone call
when did i step out of limo i have no
idea because everything was just moving
so quickly after that um
yeah it happened like a flash i mean i
think you know maybe you don't want to
tell us but it's okay
[Laughter]
so when did you learn what had happened
with claire
so in your mind right now is this over
yeah okay
okay congratulations you've just blown
up the bachelorette
were you nervous about the pressure of
that and and what your feelings might be
like and how fast
they would move they did share to me
that
um you know if things were continuing to
move with that they had
that claire might have found her love
already i didn't know
much more than that and so i didn't
really ask many questions
just because if it was gonna be my
opportunity i wanted to kind of
have my own experience with it all my
question is
did you feel pressure to not have the
same type of love story as claire or do
you have the same
type did you meet your husband on your
night one t-shirt
[Laughter]
i don't know you just have to wait and
see but um no i didn't really feel any
pressure
to be honest i just wanted to give
myself a chance an opportunity and see
if it was possible
so did you feel like you met your
husband on night one
there were some cute men i'll tell you
that much i don't know about all that
saying cute is about a hundred times
less than what claire said
um well ultimately how do you feel
your season is different than claire's
how would you contrast the two
um well it lasted a few more weeks but
other than that
um you just really see a lot of the men
that you're not seeing
that you haven't previously seen and um
the guys
are incredible incredible um but they
did make me cry
um there are some really fun dates there
are
a lot of twists and turns i don't know
it was a really good season
i'm truly giving it a chance and it's
more than what i've ever opened up
myself to
but also i have to follow my heart well
abc exec rob mills he did an interview
and he said that you fall in love with
multiple guys so what do you have to say
to that how many guys do you fall for
um way more than i thought i didn't know
that it was possible to fall in love
with multiple people but
when you just really lean into the
journey and um really be vulnerable
you never know what can happen and it
happened to me so this season has proven
that
a hundred times over how many times
do you say i love you oh that's a good
question
to how many people do you say i love you
oh that's that's
that's an even to see your question i
say it multiple times
to multiple guys um you'll just have to
wait and see
okay um like claire
did you look up the guys before you went
in because you had the opportunity to
you know what i looked at it when they
were first released for claire
so that was months ago because of
quarantine everything kind of got moved
back
um but i did not slip them up after that
and i was really happy i didn't because
i didn't really know what i was walking
into i had forgotten about everybody at
that point okay so
were you disappointed dale wasn't there
yeah uh i didn't know his i didn't know
he would be there anyway so
sounds like you did not do quite as much
digging as claire did um
no you mentioned the guys make you cry i
i want to talk about a few
moments in the promo that we have we see
you crying on the side of the road
saying you can't do this anymore what
can't you do anymore what is that moment
about
i will say that the guys just give a lot
they are so vulnerable and there are so
much depth to them
and they really open up to me and
at that point you're starting to really
create relationships and really care
about these people and
breaking up is part of the journey that
nobody really talks about but that's the
hardest part
once you're starting to establish
relationships and connections and
yeah that's kind of why i start crying
because you can't
break up with people anymore well
because it's starting to get
really real you feel a lot of things was
it i mean you're somebody who'd been in
talks for this
as we've said for a long time
was this whole thing more intense more
real
more what than you'd ever imagined um
absolutely it's harder than i had
imagined it sounds
it's all glitz and glam if you think
about it lots of gowns and
you have like a lot of men vying for
your heart in suits and like it's fun
and games
but it's it's really intense
journey to find the love of your life
well we also see you
in a white dress in the promo so tasha
nothing about that says anything other
than proposal moment
do you get proposed to this season
um i do wear a wedding dress i will say
that
you wear a wedding dress um
okay there's probably some photo shoot
on a date or something i know you only
got so many date options at lakita
tasha you are wearing a white dress
standing alone
everything about what we've known for
this franchise of this franchise for 20
years says proposal
so you're standing there and you're
crying what is happening in that moment
um it all just hitting me
i mean it's it moves so fast are those
happy tears or sad tears
oh that's a good question um
you'll just have to wait and see i've
been waiting for you tasia so now i've
got a lot of questions
um are you engaged right now
um possibly
are you in love right now um
possibly okay no ring on your finger
doesn't mean much to me
it could be right off camera um all
right well
when uh we also see a couple moments
with these guys
uh in the promo it looks like brendan
ivan and zach
well tell me about brendan okay so
brendan
is someone that stuck out to me night
one
and um i don't know if i can say all of
this
i really want to give you the tea
but um i end up having
a one-on-one date with him okay
is he one of the guys you fall in love
with i don't know
you'll just have to wait and see i'm 100
convinced that
tasha can be my wife tasha's my dream
girl
and i could see myself falling in love
with her
asia yes i'm falling
well in the promo we straight up see
zach saying he's falling in love with
you so it seems like things get to a
certain place with zach
tell me about your connection with zach
he is someone that
has depth to him that was willing to go
those places i'm telling you right now
these guys
are vulnerable they're open they're
honest they're real
well taisha you're someone who has been
you know you've been divorced i think
maybe people don't understand how much
you really were wanting to find love how
ready were you are you to get married
um it's so funny so right before
quarantine happened i was like you know
what i am
ready today i'm ready to get out there
and then of course quarantine hit and
i was by myself in my my apartment but
then i went on this journey so i have
been ready to find my person
for a while now and
this is the right way this is the right
opportunity too now do you feel like
these guys give you a fair chance is
there a concern that they're too wrapped
up in claire and that they're not
excited for you
um that was definitely a fear of mine
that they weren't going to be able to
kind of switch their mindset
um but they do welcome me with open arms
and you will be seeing that
and how excited they all were and how
fun it's going to be
how could they not welcome you with open
arms i didn't really believe that
concern i'm like really
and what do they have going on outside
the resort they have nothing to leave
for i mean come on
um let's talk about something really
important which is uh that you are the
second black bachelorette in franchise
history
how did that feel for you to take that
mantle on um
to do it especially after everything
that had happened this year
well not only am i the second
african-american bachelorette but i'm
also i'm biracial i'm also mexican
so it is just an amazing
opportunity that i've been given to have
a platform for women that are like me to
see somebody represented and
for me to find love and just show what
that looks like
because it's a beautiful journey and i'm
happy that i'm able to have that
platform to do so
what do you think this means for the
franchise because we've now had peter
who is cuban
we have matt we have you it's it's the
first time we've had back-to-back
um you know people of color in the lead
so how does that feel for you and what
do you think it means for the future
well i think that that just goes to show
that people are trying
and the world is changing and as it
right
like as it should love it comes in all
different shades and colors and
it looks like this you know what i mean
so
the fact that you're starting to see
that on television displayed is
a step in the right direction we're both
biracial and you know we have this
beautiful love story developing
and how much do we see any of those
conversations happen there's a part in
the promo where you and ivan talk about
being mixed race
um yeah and and for me
i was also given the opportunity to date
people that i might have not had the
opportunity to
and that's the part for me that honestly
i keep
saying i'm so blessed because i met some
fantastic men
now do we have a villain this season
because the promos look like we might
who is it are there guys you wish claire
had warned you about
i mean you know possibly
but the guy they're good guys
they're good guys but there's some
people you should probably watch for
well
you said the the guys you didn't we
didn't really get to know them on clear
season
how many new guys do you get and do you
connect more with the new guys or the
ones who were
there for claire i have to say i
there's some new faces and it's gonna
get really juicy
the second that happens so just wait and
[Music]
see